so in these questions of the Summa tale
ODI we're looking at will and we're
looking at free will and so this is
really whether you realize that are not
this is about self-knowledge when we
think of will we don't think of
knowledge right we're thinking of
choices and your responsibilities and
walking to whether you're good person or
a bad person and maybe about how you
resist temptation I'm talking about
using willpower but really if we're
studying Thomas part this is about self
knowledge because who he has a will
everyone should raise your hand right
because if you didn't raise your hand
you chose not to raise your hand right
you use your will one way or the other
and who's got free will again all we
have free will maybe you're not
convinced of it maybe you think that
your will is determined that it's not up
to you animals don't have free well
other animals besides us all the things
besides us in Thomas's scheme do have to
be well-liked like angels you know so if
you believe in angels presumably they
they get to make their own choices now
you might say why why is he talking
about these two things why not just talk
about will he's actually using two
different terms that don't get
translated quite so well in the English
will and Latin is ballin tossed it's the
same word that Anselm use it's the same
word that Augustine use is talking about
will that's the Latin word for will your
faculty of choice your your ability to
choose one thing or the other that by
which you ask
make your choices right you always have
this in you as it is a human being this
is the tree in our [ __ ] reham is the
commune judgment like when you actually
come to some sort of judgment about
something should I go to should you guys
are registering for classes right I
think this is this week or next week
this week next week okay so you're going
to make some decisions your advisor is
going to especially give a very hands-on
advisor they might like say I've got all
figured out for you I know exactly what
you're taking but it's up to you write
your glasses your that your body's got
to be in those seats you've got to get
yourself up at that time so you better
actually make your own choice about what
classes you're going to take I'm not
saying you know argue with your dice or
anything like that but you you know you
ought to you know assert yourself so
that's a judgment and if you take
certain classes you said hey you know I
looked at the catalog and I really want
to major in this and I think this would
be a good classroom you to take it this
time nearby just well I don't know and
you say no look here's the reasons why
you're giving a judgment and you're
backing up your judgment with reasons
right hopefully some of you do that if
you've got you know pushy advisors on
the other hand if you have a totally
hands-off unengaged advisor you may have
to do a lot of the judging on you're
wrong and you know figuring out how to
work with somebody that's a matter of
this sort of thing to libra means free
yeah we don't we get the word liberal
from that liberal arts the free arts not
pretty like in the sense that we teach
us for free where you get it for free
you know that
case haircuts right but in the case that
they helped to make you more free person
they'll to free your mind our bedroom
can also mean choice itself the decision
that you make their lives within within
your powers yeah so you know what
handsome was talking about on the
freedom of choice it was de Libertad our
victory on freedom of the Faculty of
choice yeah obviously was talking about
on the free choice of the will it was
similarly nothing well so that's why
he's using these two terms 82 is about
the will itself 83 is about the will in
this particular manifestation as free
choice so we're going to look at at a
bunch of different issues here and the
first thing that he starts out with is
thinking about this do you you do make
choices our your choice is forced upon
you by necessity and we looked at some
of this stuff in terms of Ansul right if
I hold a gun to your head and I say
let's say you have done to and I say
you're going to shoot that other person
where I'm going to shoot you sort of
thing that happens in movies right or
maybe out you're going to push a button
and then somebody'll get poisoned Jersey
act or something like that you would say
well I am being forced I have a gun to
my head right and we saw that with the
insult well no you actually do have some
some matter of choice with that you can
choose whether to say screw you I'm
going to do I'm going to do the right
thing you're not going to make me do it
or you can you know say give me some
time to think about this or you can say
sure I'll pull the trigger you there's a
whole variety of things that you could
do and the mere fact that you feel
yourself under compulsion doesn't mean
that
you don't actually have some some choice
right now Thomas has this understanding
of the will where it's what he calls
intellectual appetite and the
intellectual the appetite is directed to
the good now what's the mean
intellectual appetite when you see
appetite another word that you can think
of that I think would be helpful during
the desire you have within you desire
all the time going on then you hear
experiencing desire more often in terms
of particular things right what's one
thing you desire right now I would guess
most of you yeah you'd like to go back
to back right our dogs woke us up at
five in the morning today and I was I
was ticked off because you know I wanted
to at least sleep into like six because
I don't teach as well when when I'm you
know still kind of sleepy and as you get
older you need more sleep you know we
don't need more sleep but if you don't
get it gets tougher you know you guys
actually need more sleep your body's
need more sleep right now in my body
does I need about eight hours you guys
need about the average of nine hours how
many of you are getting nine hours of
sleep tonight not view right so you're
all sleep deprived you you you know as
the class goes on it's kind of warm in
here you're sitting you're going to that
desire is going to get stronger and
stronger right how many do you have
breakfast okay so only a third of the
class I actually ate something before
coming over here are the rest of you
hungry are those of you who even ate
breakfast it's still a little hungry
here's your bodies are still growing you
have felt people tending small breakfast
then they
we big lunches and dinners that's a
desire right all of you manage to get
yourself here in class in part because
you have other desires to you want the
other desire to succeed and that's
something that you may not have like
thought about but it's I'm going isn't
it's part of your life you guys are
pretty goal driven era students you know
it's right as far as my experience goes
especially eight o'clock classes tend to
have the students who are particularly
go-getters you know done all of your
classmates are here anymore to some of
the mark go-getters yeah they fall by
the wayside you have some other desires
that are even more basic that run
throughout your your entire life that
bridge whether you realize it or not you
have a desire to be locked by other
people which is natural to you that's
part of what makes us human being you
have a desire to find things that are
fulfilling for you that may be tied
together with this desire to succeed
right success for a lot of you will
probably include some sort of job that
you find fulfilling that cultivates your
talents that puts the good things in you
to work and Thomas says that the
greatest desire that you have for the
universal good is for happiness
all of us desire to be happy we all
desire out some other things to it
Aristotle says all human beings by Kate
your desire to know there's something
for every single one of you that you
would like to know it may not be you
know what Thomas Aquinas a lot of
something but there's something that
you're attracted to but even more basic
than that happiness now this isn't the
same thing necessarily in the shape that
we conceive of that for all of us you
know the components of happiness a happy
life will not be exactly the same thing
we get down to the nitty-gritty but in
the broad straws to remember will is
intellectual appetite the intellect
graphs things in terms of universal the
abstract and the intellect grasps proved
right so I that last class you have
other appetites you have other desires
but they may not be as general as this
desire for happiness that's always
motivating Thomas thanks from from the
time when you're a little baby you
probably conceived of happiness is like
you know being warm not being wet
getting to eat well sort of babies like
to look at things and smile have other
people smile at them and play right then
you've progressed through childhood and
adolescence and now here you are young
adults still to some degree growing
physically your minds are not your brain
is not completely developed until it's
about 25 years old but your body did
more or less done right you're about as
tall good morning you're about as tall
as you're going to be unfortunately you
know if you're not happy with your
height you wrestle a while all right if
you're anything you're too tall there's
nothing you can do about that either but
you're not just physically
develop your also developed as far as
like your intellect and your will as
adults is adult human beings you're now
rational and you're now directed towards
the human hood towards what it is it
makes our lives fulfilling and for
Thomas Aquinas ultimately he thinks this
is God but you know does everybody
conceive of it that way no because we
have all different of notions of
happiness somewhere more vague some are
well worked out some are some are not
worked out and you don't really need to
worry about that and we make these
articles that were looking at work so
he's interested in this question that
look if this is always in the background
and the will is always directed to this
didn't you say the will is you know what
allows me to choose one thing or another
but if I'm always directed to the same
thing am I really able to choose or
isn't something kind of like making me
do it like I have a destiny and no
matter what I choose to do and I always
wind up at the same place you seen some
movies like that all right or somebody
can't avoid the prophecy about them or
you know I guess remember do you guys
remember Groundhog Day this will do the
same thing over and over again until he
finally gets it right and that breaks
the spell that's an interesting movie
about about freedom of choice whether
you realize it or not they were there
thinking about metaphysical issues so
the will you know is the will really
free or is it necessitated he's doing to
ask so let's let's look at this article
one says whether the will desire
something of necessity and we'll look at
some of the objections we won't do that
for all of them he says objection what
it would seem that will desires nothing
for Augustine says that if anything is
necessary it's not voluntary but
whatever the will desires is voluntary
so nothing that the will desires is
desired
necessity so you know this matches on to
a lot of people's understanding of what
it means to be a free agent to have will
if I'm making you will something in a
particular way your Luck's free right if
I force you what about it something
inside of your course do you think about
if you're like an addict we don't say
that the addicts are free they're
they're compelled towards something so
maybe that's Augustine they said further
the rational power is according to the
philosopher extend two opposite things
what it means to be rational is to be
able to like layout options and say well
I'm going to take this instead of this
think about when you do a math problem
and there's multiple choice right you
get this you get you know it could be
this could be this could be this could
be this you pick the right answer you
pick the right answer out of a range of
possible answers right two plus two
equals four or could it equal five none
of you think it does right hope because
if you do your calculations are going to
be an often tax time is not a good time
for that the government won't accept I
think two plus two equals five I just
had this is this problem
well yeah you might be like you know
calculating the refund I think most of
you guys are getting refunds right yeah
would depend very much on which which
way it's going with that but your your
reason is able to decide between things
when you screw up and make a math
mistake like if you ever retrace your
steps you're like haha here's where I
did the wrong thing now you're able to
do that because reason is able to go
different directions if the little only
goes one direction then maybe it's not
it's not free but the will is supposed
to be a rational power so maybe this is
this doesn't actually hold maybe the
will can go in whatever direction at
once they says further by the will were
masters of her own actions we're not
masters of that which is a necessity
therefore the act of the will cannot be
necessitated he's not quoting any
authority through this because this is a
very basic sort of you know off-the-cuff
kind of argument about what it means to
have free will if we want to say
somebody is actually free and they have
a will they can choose things don't we
just mean that they can they can go this
way or they can go this way to say that
they have to go this way all the time
that's a little weird that seems to
contradict that so he says the word
necessity is employed in many ways and
so what we see here Thomas doing is
making a distinction this is something
that you know we do as philosophers
quite a bit you've seen this happen over
the course of the semester with
different thinkers Thomas is sort of the
master of making distinctions generally
if there's some sort of weird puzzle
that you know things don't add up
somebody needs to make a distinction
somewhere and then look at the parts of
more carefully so he says what do we
mean when we're talking about necessity
since the thing that a thing must be may
belong to it by what we call it
the Christmas something in that thing
either material like when we say that
everything composed of contraries is of
necessity corruptible that's a little
hard as an example of wrap your head
around what he means by that is
everything that's built up on parts that
don't necessarily jive with each other
can break down right like your body your
body can break down you can't have a
human body that that won't never break
down as a matter of fact you might say
well longevity techniques and stuff like
that your cells are constantly dying and
being replaced by yourselves right so
there's an internal necessity to that
you can't like you know will it's not
going to be that way or formal like when
we say it's necessary for the three
angles of a triangle to be equal the two
right angles triangle adds up to 100
degrees right can you make a triangle
assuming that you're not doing any weird
non-euclidean geometry can you make a
triangle that's not going to add up to
180 degrees the three angles its stack
of work right that's what it means to be
a triangle that's part of what it or can
you make a square that only has three
three angles why not exactly that came
to thicken up that square that's what he
calls a formal necessity of it and
that's one kind of necessity that's very
important it says in another way that a
thing must be able long stood by reason
of something extrinsic something not in
the thing but outside of the thing now
how could that happen well one way that
he talks about this is an agent like I
you know a little forget about the gun
to your head let's say I want to make
you slap somebody so I grabbed your hand
physically and I walk I'm like walking
around like a
or something I've whacked the other
person across the face I need you do
that right now imagine it all sort of
science fictiony kind of things there's
a chimp inside of your head and I've got
it I've got the controls and I'm making
you walk up to the person the newhall
off when you whack them in the face you
didn't really choose to do that right I
made you do it that was what he calls
compulsion or coercion here in this
that's that's a type of necessity we say
I couldn't help but do it was
necessitated there's a third kind of the
d2x but as well it says on the part of
the end when without at the end is not
to be attained or so well attained now
what does he mean by end this is kind of
a technical term when you have a goal
when you have something that you desire
that is your app so what was your end at
getting yourself here this morning's
participation grade okay or could you
know get in the classroom you know you
get a multiple hear what dr. Sandler has
to say about this kill sometimes I can't
stand a roommate they're away the
beautiful stars impossible that's some
of which are connected with what we're
doing some of which may not be connected
fulfill my obsessional habit of always
being in every place
particular good end with some people
have that it's now right so we talk
about means tattoo right there are some
things that are our ends and then we
choose means to fulfill that so like
what was the means there are multiple
means but what was one means for getting
yourself here in classroom taking a walk
something even if you park your car and
you drove here you took a walk for a
little little what that was a means that
F now on the part of the ad you says
when without at the end is not to be
attained or so well attainment for
example food is necessary for life if
you want to stay alive that's not to say
that all you have to do is eat right
there's other things you get to do but
if you don't need you're going to die
right if you don't drink water or other
things that have water it may take you
awhile but you're going to die there's
other things that are necessary for life
here right can't do without that
material
there might be some other things too
that I'm not getting the way in bullets
but you know that that's more coercion
kind of thing now he says a horse is
necessary for a jerk is a horse the only
way you can go on a journey definitely
not because we don't we don't ride
horses these days anymore right back in
Thomas's time that was that was the best
way to go get out of horse a plane is
necessary for joining a train car your
feet a bike you could go down go down
the whole list i thought the Ox driven
cart you know in certain areas he calls
this a necessity event now necessity of
coercion he says is repugnant to the
world when I take your hand and I slap
somebody else's face with it you did not
will that it actually went against your
well he says we call that violent or
coerce which is against the inclination
of the thing but the movement of the
will is an inclination is something what
about necessity of n what about choosing
something because it's going to lead to
something else he says that's number
abundance a little when the enemy cannot
be attained in with it except in one way
so if you want to cross the ocean let's
assume there's no claims at this time
Thomas is ready what do you have to do
what's that you got to get on a boat
yeah he says if you if you if your will
is too if your inclination is across the
sea to get to say great britain you got
to get on a ship there's no two ways
about it you could say way I now we
could take a plane sure and a plane is
doing the same thing as a chef it's
crossing over the water you can't take a
car can you unless you have like a bowl
car that car so they
like that turns into a plane so he says
in like manner neither is natural
necessity repugnant to the will indeed
more than this the intellect of
necessity of years to first principles
there's certain basic things that all of
you know and you couldn't get by the
world without them these are what he
calls first principles and says the will
must of necessity adhere to the last s
what is the last end the presenter
sometimes we call the final em and then
of last end it doesn't mean that this
comes last in your life this is what
your will is ultimately driving for this
is the last thing in the chain of
somebody asking you well I well I well
wow if we think about why are you here
in this classroom so you can get a good
great right why do you want to get a
good grade you just want to you want to
graduate why do you want to graduate get
a good job why do you want to get a good
job and then a lot of us are like wow we
just do right but really if you think
about it you want a good job ultimately
for the sake of happiness because you
want to be happy because you don't want
to work some some crap job that you're
unhappy and you want to be able to
supply yourself with the other things
you need for happiness like having a
nice house being able to provide for
your family and you know being able to
enjoy time with your friends being able
to go on vacation to purchase things
that you like to change your wardrobe
more than once every 10 years we just go
down the whole list right all these
things Thomas thinks are ultimately for
the sake of happiness this is greatest
good in our life so he says the will
must have necessity adhere to the last
end which is happiness though the end is
in practical matters with the principle
is in speculative manners when we're
trying to think about what should i do
we start from where do I want to get to
what is it I'm trying to achieve and
then we kind of work our way back well I
want to be happy I got to get a good
I want to get a good job a better
graduate because it's tough to get a
good job even with a you know 24 month
and really tough to get it without it
you know the this is what he calls
necessities so he says what befits a
thing naturally de movably must be the
routan all in principle of all else a
pertaining to so you know for instance
plants what if plants want to do plants
are aiming at hampton was planters
damning like rules and reproduction
animals have a lot more to the picture
they like to eat things they like to
play some of them at least insects nuts
and watch dogs and cats but bit they
want affection but a dog doesn't have
this overarching conception of happiness
like like we do that that's rise that
drives our will so the will is of
necessity driven towards happiness but
it's not doing so improving let's go on
to the next one because he's going to
talk more about necessity what about the
other things that we could is it
necessary that we will once we start
saying yeah something's could be
necessary for the will maybe all things
that we will we can so he says it would
seem that the will desires all things of
necessity whatever it desires so you
know he's recording DNS is here actually
pseudo DMSO ceases evil is outside of
the scope will therefore the will tens
of necessity to the good which is
proposed to sew a really basic example
somebody provides me with a cup of
coffee and I like coffee my desire is
for the coffee to begin me you know to
taste it to consume it for the effect of
the caffeine all answers up I drink the
coffee the coffee compelled me to do so
it's the good it made me want it I had
to happen and therefore that's why you
know can't stop myself you know we know
that's not the case but the other could
be some things like that some things
that a person can see is good where it
just like makes them pursue it I think
says further the object of the Wills
compared to the will as the mover to the
thing movable so the object of the will
is what it is if you want the will not
only has desire for happiness and he has
desire for good things all sorts of good
things things you think are good which
are you know hopefully they lead to
happiness but you also want them
oftentimes for their own sake if that
end can move the will can't these ends
move the will that cause what we call
inclinations
you'll see you're walking across campus
and it's it's at night and there's
nobody around and see a hundred-dollar
bill on the ground if you pick it up how
many of you acquit to say this is none
of my business I'm going to leave that
that that's hundred dollars all alone
what's that times are hard yeah okay
there's a lot you can do the hundred
dollars yet dollar bill can't do much
with that I think even a dollar bill a
lot of people I see people betting down
sometimes to pick up a nickel or a daddy
that's found property why well because
we like money right then it draws a
little bill now imagine here so there's
sort of an example like this imagine
you're walking through one of these
buildings and again it's real late at
night and there's like a whole spread of
food up somewhere you're hungry and you
know obviously it was because there was
some sort of meeting or something like
that and they just left the food there
are you gonna take some of the food no
okay
whoa so you're worried when you poison
or something like that now notice that
the only thing I kept you from doing it
is in a worry about some other good
thing I don't want to die you know I
don't want to be sick health security
that sort of thing what actually makes
her will do it it doesn't he says the OP
the movement of the movable necessarily
follows the mover so it seems that the
Wills object moves it by necessity so
are the things that we choose making us
choose them that's what he's asked he
says the will does not a desire
necessity whatever it desires in order
to make this evident we have to observe
that as the intellect naturally adheres
the first principles Solar will adheres
to the last act now there's some things
intelligible which don't have a
necessary connection with the first
principles like contingent propositions
like I am what's a contingent
proposition a proposition which could be
true or false depending on what the
circumstances are I am here in the
classroom at nine-thirty that will no
longer be the case right somebody else
will be here presumably and the
statement dr. Sadler is in this place at
nine thirty will be a false statement
that's a contingent proposition doesn't
follow from any sort of inherent
necessity of things the only reason I'm
actually here at this time is because
they scheduled me here at this time
that's why you're here at this time
right it could be differently as a
matter of fact I could like some
professors do say everyone's going to go
outside we're going to experience major
or something like this I don't have
anything like that the syllabus
unfortunately but you know that's a
possibility right so he says
there are somethings intelligible which
you would jolly the necessary connection
with the first principles contingent
proposition there's some other
propositions then do you have a
necessary connection with the first
principles such as demonstrable
conclusions a denial of which involves
the denial of the first principle so now
it's a good idea for me to tell you like
some what some of these principles a
thing cannot be and not be at the same
time that makes you view self-evident
right of course that's the case well
that's because it's the first principle
now if you're if you're working out some
sort of line of reasoning and you get
that a is the case and not a is the case
at the same time in the same way you
know something got screwed up somewhere
we call this a reductio ad absurdum yeah
what about further lose 10 Schrodinger's
cat is neither here nor there we don't
we don't know which are yours cat is the
example of the cap that we don't know
whether it's live or not until we
actually open up the case because the
theoretically could be alive or dead
yeah and until we know we have to say
it's both at the same time that would
seem to violate that really when it
comes out to we just don't know it's not
that that both alive and dead at the
same time that's a way in which we're
trying to conceive of it but when you do
that your mind recoils from it right
that's because it's a first principle
aerosol would say and Thomas would say
that it's either a or it's not you gotta
pick one or the other now is there
anything like that for the well there
are like it says there are some things
that we can't help it desire happiness
there's something that we have to be
inclined towards happiness whatever that
is and then there's all sorts of all the
things he says there's certain
individual goods which which do not have
a necessary connection with happiness
because without them a man can be can be
happy can you be happy without being
filthy rich yeah a lot of people who who
are as a matter of fact if you could
only be happy by being filthy rich
very few people would be happy at all
right and I sort of be wasting my time
talking about this because you're
probably not to be filthy rich you know
it's like the fact that you probably
would like to be when would you like to
win the lottery and never have to be
compelled to work you not only work at
the things that you want to the rest of
your life it's a good thing to be to be
to be wealthy but it's not necessary for
happiness can you be happy imagine that
the world all the books in the world
disappeared overnight including ones on
my Kindle is you know computers and
stuff like that all the world's
literature to disappear if I screw this
we're looking at right now would it be
possible for you to be empty you don't
think so I mean I love books you
probably turn right and we love the act
of reading books and there's probably
been like tangible things like it's nice
to get a new book and then I open it up
and old books have that kind of some of
them have a bad smell but something have
a you know get a nice paper smells
really good paper but you could be happy
without it it is possible I mean for us
because of our habits and inclinations
that we've developed it's a really
central component of our happiness and
48 report Hayes actually said I can see
the paradise as much like a library
that's just paraphrasing I'm not
actually getting the quote right because
there is such a big bibliophile which
perhaps is your case it was my case we
could be happy with that it's not
absolutely necessary
he says there are some things which have
a necessary connection with happiness by
means of which man adheres to god you're
home alone true happiness consists so
there are some things that we would have
to have in order to be truly happy and
those things do necessitate the will
when we get it and you can we take out
of the picture let's say happiness is
just something like living a full human
complete life in this this life itself
if you think about it to yourself aren't
there some things you would have to have
in order for that to be the case once
you've realized that you would have to
have those your will is making me
inevitably attraction to those things
but if you haven't figured that out yet
like let's say you haven't experienced
those things you all have the experience
I think in your life having new
experiences when it comes to desires
where you you didn't realize until now
that if you don't have this thing your
life is really not going to be as
complete it could be a person you know
you realize because they want to weigh
on vacation how much you miss them and
now your life you realize we have movies
right where this happens the hero or the
euro and now I realize I love you so
much enough gana got to be with you
forever blah blah you know romantic
substitute whatever else you like in
there what's that all about that's about
thinking that that person is an integral
part of your happiness and once you
actually feel that way your will have to
go that way but until you feel that way
it doesn't what if you get it wrong what
if you have a fundamental a mistake in
understanding of what happiness is like
let's say you you grow up in a really
rough area dollars where people are
beating each other up all the time and
you come to think that happiness is like
security and being respected by
everybody else and being able to do
whatever you want to anybody whatever
you want to then
an integral part of your happiness might
be having power exercising power over
other people you might say I got to do
whatever it takes to have that power
your will is going to be inevitably
attracted to that from a mistaken
consumption so there are some things
that you necessitate are Willie says
move on a little bit more I'm going to
skip through fairly quick this and
whether the Wills a higher power than
the intellect now that may not be quite
so interesting to you just to me because
these questions about what actually
makes us choose what does he mean by it
is the will of higher power than the in
flight basically it comes down to this
what who's running the show is that
first we think about things and then we
we find ourselves attracted to them and
then pursue them and do them or does the
will get to exercise an influence on
upon the intellect and nothing's going
to say obviously doesn't see handsome
appliances answer is yes and no with
this generally speaking the intellect is
higher than the will generally speaking
the intellectus is really running the
show in the last analysis it's up to the
influence to tell us what to do but the
will has a lot of a role and it can tell
the intellect what to do in some cases
so he says the superiority of one thing
over another can be considered in two
different ways absolutely and relatively
so if we compare the objects of the will
in the intellect what does the intellect
is the intellect grasps truth grasps
things as they are grasps what there is
that's intelligible in them Thomas
things that's better than Greta than
sort of extending ourselves and
inclining ourselves to to good thing the
intellect can think about the idea of
the good it can it can know the good the
will can just desire they're good it can
move us towards the good you know who
would you say it is better off the
person who knows something or the person
who does something the person who knows
something should be able to do it right
I think about the person who's got the
owner's manual just assume that they
actually have the power to do with it
but they understand right because in
this case that is like you know it's an
intellect of them person I know there
are cases where there are people who
talk a good game seem to know something
that can't actually do it because that's
a matter of practical experience that's
that doesn't really apply this basic
intellect and will so he says the more
simple and more abstract thing is the
nobler and hired is in itself so in
general the object of the intellect is
higher than the object of the will but
relatively and by comparison with
something else we find that the will
sometimes higher than the intellect from
the fact the object of the will occurs
in something higher than that in which
occurs the option of the intellect
what's he talking about there so we
doubt at all graceful and we got into
those are in the person and the will is
directed to some so good the intellect
understands the good and bring an idea
of the good or concept or however you
want to put it it's probably somebody
who's going to watch this video and like
I don't want to correct me Thomas says
blah blah blah blah because there's
always so many when it comes to promise
the intellect generates an idea of
itself inside of itself whatever it is
on the outside right so imagine coffee
right now I'm going to be like coffee
most of them okay so those are you two
don't we don't imagine you do like
clapping right that you're attracted to
coffee because probably something will
be you your will desires the coffee and
the coffee is actually outside of you
and the idea of coffee is inside of you
that's how you're able to grasp this is
actually cough you take a sip mmm tastes
like coffee you know you have a sense
impression your mind is working the same
yes that thing out there maps onto this
idea I've got truly that is coffee right
now Thomas says that in general this is
actually better than this and you know
think about all the different things
that you have desired and experience and
how infrequently the experience measures
up to the idea that you had beforehand
of the thing that you wanted I'm going
to go see this movie and it's going to
be the best movie ever right and then
you're like yeah I wouldn't watch it
again glad I got to see it was a good
thing but not that good I'm going to go
out of his date and it's going to be the
best date ever you know your man
things and sometimes there's even cases
where like your memories of the thing or
better than how I actually went because
you like left out you'd have strict it
this Thomas would say from certain
things well you've got that still inside
of you actually in that case it's in the
memory not the intellect but you can see
the general idea now he says that the
idea of the thing is in the one who
understands the act of the will
consistent things and this the will is
inclined to the thing is existing itself
so the thing the good is something
besides usual and he says on when
therefore the thing in which there is
good is nobler than the soul itself in
which the which is the idea understood
by comparison was such a thing the will
is higher than the intellect so what
would be an example of that what is
there are many things that are lesser
than you that are not as valuable as you
once think about those for example
coffee comes down to saving you or
saving the co op ed I'm going to save
save you that's because I'm rightly
directed by save the coffee instead
there's something wrong you got a
fundamental level I'm not recognizing
the value of a human your monthly it
comes between sparing your feelings and
having the cup of coffee I would be more
inclined to spare your feelings but
that's a little bit of a tougher
situation what about a car cars are
pretty valuable more valuable than a
human being we shouldn't see it that way
if we're seeing things right what about
knowledge some people sacrifice
everything for knowledge is relative
skill still that knowledge itself is not
as good necessarily as a human being so
what could be greater than a human being
the whole created universe minus human
beings Thomas would actually say all
this stuff patek human beings out of it
is not worth
single rational human soul a rational
human soul is more valuable than all of
non-rational creation put together
that's how valuable he thinks you are so
is there anything that could be greater
in value of the human soul thomas's yeah
did you take one for the match 114 well
you'd be comparing human souls against
human souls that I suppose I was
thinking about this earlier Thomas might
be inclined to say that a community as a
community not just as a bunch of people
but as a community where there's greater
shared goods that are developed within
the community could be greater than the
individual so real politics where we're
not just thinking about how to get
elected or about you know how to dole
out thanks to all of our friends but
about the common good and about how to
actually achieve the common good which
almost none of our politicians are
interested in this necessary Republicans
or Democrats that could be something
greater than the salt thing from up from
a touristic perspective whatever I get
mine from this this article is actually
got now the idea that we gave of God is
the idea that we have whatever it is of
God anything even remotely close to what
we think God would actually be or our
ideas inadequate may be too small not
not fully grasping what is good this
ultimate good
what would be even if you don't believe
God think about you know the different
ideas that people have of God some ideas
are much more exalted some ideas are
count kind of low some of them actually
just sort of like look like them only
with a lot more power you know you
wouldn't want that guy running the show
would you God is an extremely vengeful
and Petty and bitter whatever that
person happens something good thinks
that's wrong we don't want that Oh God
but even now imagine very enlightened
you know thoughtful conceptions of that
if there really is a gap could those
ideas measure up to human being is a
finite thing right we we have some of
the most you know amazing processors in
our brains compared to anything else in
the universe but even so if there is a
gap God would be infinite God would be
transcendent to our idea and the widdle
Thomas has desires got so the will in a
certain way is doing better than the
intellect if the good is actually higher
than they would be in and God is
presumably being then in this case the
will is created but only in that sort of
case like it says the love of God which
we feel through our will through our
desire for God is greater than the
knowledge of God you wouldn't say that
about coffee the love of coffee is
greater than the knowledge of coffee now
the knowledge is better you wouldn't say
that even about music something in a
result be the love of music is greater
than the knowledge of music know the
knowledge of music this is greater
he goes on then he says does the will
move the intellect is it possible for
the will to make the intellect do what
did once and he says you know the
arguments that people say or no other
will can't do that because the intellect
is what runs the show intellect supplies
the ideas and then the wind begins to 21
books so for you know let's use an
example from your own experience why did
you want to come to this class because
good be great yeah and really it started
with this larger project of graduating
that of course you know you need a great
offense your intellect is doing that
that's knowledge on your part and you
also like looked at all the requirements
for graduation you saw that intro to
philosophy is one of those requirements
right so you're like yeah I'm going to
take a intro to philosophy class you
know those that most of you probably
said you know got to get it out of the
way eight o'clock not my happiest time
but I'll do it or you know okay a lot of
things I going to do eight o'clock that
allow me to practice you've carried out
some sort of intellectual process and
then you desire it then you went to your
advisor to hey I want this class put it
on my cue cards some sort or just enter
it electronically electronically now so
electronic class request for level and
that was your will well but you have to
have the idea first right this is why a
lot of people say we should we should be
you know century asst about altars of
moral things like they thank you notes
on the internet you have this wide open
world because kids can get all sorts of
ideas from the internet right now just
from horror like you know if you want to
figure out how to make a explosive you
can go on the internet find it you know
it's a couple clicks right what's up
City have to be careful that like you
have sometimes they're monitoring that
sort of thing well the reality bug is
called the Anarchist Cookbook right yeah
by a new nation they actually had been
tampered with so if you do try thanks
that's proposal that's nice than the
ball when I was a kid the asked his
cookbook was that big thing and when we
got our hands on it and I had some sort
of explosives and value improvised drugs
and like booby traps and I'll ever like
wow no this this stump and thank God we
didn't do like 99 / some of the stuff in
it but you know it wouldn't have
occurred to us to desire to do a lot of
those things and somebody not like told
us hey you know you can do this this
this thing first we have to know about
right so Thomas is a thing is set to
move in two ways first is an end for
instance when we say the N moves the
agent in this way the intellect was well
because first we understand the good and
then we're drawn to the good so the ends
like does in some way move second thing
is set to move he has an agent as what
alters moves what is altered like I move
this here what word here right I'm in
Egypt I'm doing something and what
impels mousse was in health in this way
the will remember what is the world's a
faculty of choice it's what allows us to
make decisions what allows us to the
banquets in us and do things with it the
will actually does move the intellect
you have experience of this all the time
right when you
studying for a test you are making
yourself use your mind aren't you you're
making yourself think about something
when you're writing a paper and you're
taking it information and then you're
synthesizing it you're putting it down
on the paper you are making your
intellect perform certain actions you're
choosing it why are you choosing about
looking at how whole explanation got new
paper it's good for you all that but the
key thing here is your will does
actually move the intellect if you
choose not to think about certain things
that you really want to think about
that's going to affect what you actually
have available to you isn't it if you
lie to yourself about you know certain
basic facts and human beings tell you
some people are good bad bad and they're
good you can do that you can you can
choose to screw up you're employed or to
not use it and say I don't feel like
thinking today that's within your power
let me skip ahead a little bit
Aereo he also has this weird discussion
that you probably had no idea what the
makeup where he's talking about whether
we should distinguish you rascal and
confusable parts in the superior
appetite article 5 of question 82 know
what it was he time well Thomas has this
idea we have the intellect right we have
the will and then we also have what she
calls the sensitive capitec we have is
we have a set of designers we have a set
of desires that are moving us towards
sorts particular things all the time
just like animals do right the animals
perceive certain things as likely to be
pleasurable for them or is conducive to
their nature you know and so they they
move sort of those things they desire
those things so you know think about
what it pigs roll around yeah I mean a
lot of us things like pigs just like to
wallow in filth you know because that's
the kind of things they are dirty pigs
you know but actually up has to do with
their regulation of body temperature
they know they'll sweat like we do and
they don't can't like dogs do and this
helps to actually keep their the
temperature down it also plays a role in
like helping their skin believe it
that's conducive to their nature are
they are they doing it because they just
just love to do it not not necessarily
but they're drawn to do it there are
some things that you are you know like
here's for one example why be all you
scratch right column you scratch
yourself at sometimes why why do you
scratch because you have an itch right
that's not sometimes it starts out with
a niche right and you can drive you nuts
lately
can't get to your edge like a meth and
sometimes we get a cast and people are
like gotta get to this [ __ ] because you
can't get to it and that's one thing now
after a while it starts to feel good
right when people start to keep
scratching themselves and it's about
pleasure so it could be pain or pleasure
there could also be cases where your
skin really doesn't know one sec where
your skin really does need to be
scratched you know and then we do like
things like exfoliation right scrubbing
the things people have done this for
centuries sand you know he added is good
for your skin it's conducive to your
nature Thomas was like yeah yeah some
people can have a nervous tic and then
like a kingdom cat lodge fight that
keeps scratching it breaks the skin yeah
in that case it's really not conducive
to your nature it's what we call
pathological Thomas is thinking more
about things that are that are sort of
naturally drawn to but you can have your
what is calling the Kaku stable appetite
or the irascible aptech did you record
them to the wrong things because the
force of habit now so either the cocoon
Koopa Sybil appetite is drawn to things
that are pleasurable the basketball what
is he getting that from the word for
anger and so think about what it is when
you're getting Thomas talks about anger
is something that we need in order to
attain what he calls the difficult good
what would be an example of a difficult
good security from other people who want
to mess with us or standing up in the
face of danger
achieving something in the face of
resistance that requires us not to just
pursue pleasure that requires us the
good is over there and I got it I got to
pursue it but I gotta get aim I got to
get riled up in order to be able to do
it it's not always a matter of Mangrum
hope is also a matter of the Iraq what
he calls the irascible appetite fear is
involved with it as well and they says
you rascal regards the notion of good is
something that Ward's often repels was
what is hurtful to us no does the will
will these kind of things but it doesn t
have these as parts with that because
the will this is where it gets really
interesting the will is tied to the in
flight this is what makes you different
from a dog and paying the horse a loss
cockroach you may actually can think
about things and you can actually make
choices based on your your thoughts
about so like it says the will itself
may be said to be a rascal as far as it
wills to repel evil when you decide like
to stand up to a bully which is a good
thing you are you are actually standing
up for yourself let's just say it's not
about somebody else you're standing up
for yourself you are defending a good
you are realizing it good and you have
to do it by preventing an evil which is
that other person who's a jerk having
control over you and causing you undue
fear and keeping you trapped in a
situation right Thomas would be all all
for fighting off boys yeah does that
count though if you punch it in to face
lose sympathy so yeah it's not it's not
simply about a better results I mean
that they are not talking about what
happens at the amur talking about for
the given pulse he's standing up the
choice and I says the will may be said
to be a rascal and so far as it wills to
repel evil now from any sudden movement
of
Cashin not just for the emotion that
you're feeling which is down here but
because reasons has to do that and think
about this when you really force
yourself to stand up in situations where
you're you're feeling scared and where
it might not go your way even if you do
stand up and you're like I got to do
this because I've got to like I've got
to if I don't do it this time I'm never
going to be able to do it or if you
resist any appetite you know that you
have that you say I'm not going to go
out to the bar I'm not going to gamble
something like that something where it's
very tough for people who are caught up
in that sort of thing Thomas would say
that's a matter of the intellect of will
rather than just the appetite itself
it's not just a passion it's not just an
emotion it's your shorts when you love
somebody who's a pain in the ass you
know they are sometimes they love is a
choice not just an emotion that's
exactly what he's talking about here so
in the will we can have these things
that he calls virtues like charity or
log hope and that's a matter of the ends
molecular will working that way there
are acting in divisions in the middle
like in Raskin coupe disco ball reason
why would be attractive that idea is
because those things are going on down
here we call them different things in a
our own discourse we don't talk in these
terms we talk about anger law of fear
those sorts of things attraction but
it's the same thing as Thomas's time I
want to go into before before we headed
to very quickly to weatherman has free
will this is the first question in the
first article in 83 and he goes through
a bunch of objections which I'm not
going to run through just by because of
reason of time but these are a bunch of
objections to saying that a person is
really free that their will is really
free and they're based on some
interesting ideas now what is Thomas's
basic response to this he kind of like
goes all around those and he does
respond to each of those
as well that's a lot base because this
reason that's off base but this is a
really really a passage he says look
you've got free will otherwise councils
exportations commands prohibitions
rewards and punishments would be in vain
there wouldn't be any point to any of
this business about counseling well you
ought to do this or don't do that
expectations you know that's that's
doing it more firmly commands you want
you you must do this you must not do
that prohibitions don't do that rewards
and punishments when you were good so
I'm going to give you this we were bad
so I'm going to impose this upon you if
we don't have free will Thomas says all
that is totally in vain there's no point
to any it becomes meaningless in order
to make this evident we must observe
some things act without judgment would
you punish a stone stone falls on your
head hits you you don't like that right
unless there's something wrong with you
you don't like it a hammer and break the
stone and say I'm going to fix you I'm
going to teach you right something's act
from judgment lay he says but not a free
judgment like brute animals sheep seeing
a wolf does it think to itself now what
should do in this situation it takes all
right you are different why are you
different you have like he says an
apprehensive power you judge that
something should be avoided or slot but
it's not from just natural instincts you
do have you have instance right but you
have the intellect you have reason
you're able to compare things against
each other you're able to think about
things and because of that you add from
judgment and you retain the power of
being inclined in different things you
get to choose not only what you're
acted towards and the same way of the
animal does you get to choose whether
those are going to be functioning for
you which ones you're going to allow to
take charge so you get scared right and
you make yourself do something that
you're scared to do you do that because
you realize that's good for you the dog
can't do that the dot can actually stand
up to its own fear they can take away
you know hopefully some things can take
away its fear gets experiencing anything
you are you have the capacity to choose
things in a very different way that all
of the other animals that that's what
gives you the dignity and the value that
you have and that's because the
intellect of the will are so closely
connected that's what makes you free
that's what makes me rash so that's rule
will act